cette campagne médiatique est vu comme
un sabotage pour cette can 2022 les yeux
sont rivés sur le fameux stade de limbé
confronté à des retards de travaux et un
scandale financier présumé avec le
nouveau père à la fécafoot nous savons
que les choses vont se passer pour
décidément ces pins tous les pays
africains qui seront désormais capables
d'organiser une canne à 24 équipes ne
peut pas priver africains de notre
compétition phare la
cale trois jours au cameroun et débute
le 9 janvier
[Musique]
la vague omicron déferle sur la france
plus de cent mille cas de contamination
en commis 19 en 24 heures c'est du
jamais vu depuis le début de la pandémie
un nouveau conseil de défense sanitaire
est prévue demain juste avant le conseil
des ministres qui doit adopter le projet
de loi transformant le passé ni terre en
passe maximale
l'arabie saoudite annonce une opération
militaire de grande ampleur au yémen
alors que la guerre dure depuis sept ans
maintenant la coalition intensifie ses
frappes depuis plusieurs jours avec des
bombardements ciblés notamment sur
l'aéroport de sanaa les rebelles houthi
de leur côté promettent une réponse
douloureuse
que reste-t-il des vestiges de l'urss
trente ans après sa désunion le 25
décembre 1991 le président gorbatchev
démissionne l'union soviétique disparaît
par la même occasion la fédération de
russie 15 républiques indépendantes et
14 autres états apparaissent un
événement historique qui a bouleversé
l'ordre mondial
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue si vous ne retrouvez
sur rtl france comment contrer omicron
sans paralyser le pays c'est l'une des
questions qui sera débattue demain en
conseil de défense sanitaire plus de
cent mille cas de contamination ont été
détectés sur la seule journée de noël et
professionnels de santé tire la sonnette
d'alarmé ils s'inquiètent d'une possible
saturation des hôpitaux et précision de
thibaut janin
la barre symbolique des cent mille cas
franchit jamais la france n'avait connu
autant de contamination en 24 heures un
seuil inédit depuis le début de
l'épidémie qui est venu effacer le
précédent record de la veille où plus de
94 mille cas avaient été enregistrés à
l'origine de cette flambée le variant
omicron devenu le nouvel épouvantail de
cette cinquième vague en milieu de
semaine le porte parole du gouvernement
avait déjà tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
mais l'art est aussi critique parce que
disons les choses telles qu'elles sont
l'épidémie risque de repartir en trombe
sous l'effet du variant omicron qui
circule à une vitesse phénoménale
partout en europe avec un nombre de cas
qui double tous les deux ou trois jours
il provoque des vagues brutale effréné
chez plusieurs de nos voisins et
notamment au royaume uni où des
scientifiques prévoient même plusieurs
centaines de milliers de cas par jour
dans un horizon pas si lointain
invariants qui serait beaucoup plus
contagieux et des français inquiets ces
derniers se sont précipités dans les
pharmacies pour se faire tester en cette
période de fêtes les services
hospitaliers eux font de nouveau face à
une augmentation du nombre d'admissions
en soins intensifs
seize mille cent soixante deux personnes
sont actuellement hospitalisées dont
3282 en soins critiques soit 160
nouvelles admissions en 24 heures de son
côté le président du conseil
scientifique a exprimé ses craintes
cette semaine ils redoutent des
conséquences sur les services
accueillant du public au mois de janvier
il faut s'attendre à une désorganisation
possible d'un certain nombre de services
essentiels en janvier à cause de
l'absentéisme et des arrêts de travail
dus au très grand nombre de
contaminations à osny crohn des alertes
répétées et relayés tout au long de la
semaine olivier ferrand le ministre de
la santé et emmanuel macron se sont
exprimés le chef de l'état qui
participera un conseil de défense
sanitaire lundi avant un conseil des
ministres extraordinaire le projet de
loi sur le pass vaccinale il sera
présenté si jusqu'ici l'exécutif miser
sur sa stratégie vaccinale face à la
pression du variant omicron l'hypothèse
d'un retour de mesures contraignantes
n'est plus écartée dans ce contexte de
flambée épidémique 50 professionnels de
santé ont écrit une tribune dans le
journal du dimanche lettre adressée au
ministre de la santé dans laquelle il
demande des mesures pour freiner
l'épidémie à l'école notamment en
reportant la rentrée scolaire au delà du
3 janvier il pointe du doigt le
dénigrement de certains quant à la
campagne vaccinale des enfants djillali
annane chef de service de réanimation à
l'hôpital raymond poincaré à paris est
l'un des signataires de cette tribune
la circulation du virus dans cette
tranche d'âge 5 11 ans aujourd'hui est
l'un des principaux moteurs de la
propagation du barrio mikron est donc ou
tribus très fortement au nombre élevé de
contamination quotidienne
même si la proportion d'enfants faisant
une forme sévère est faible eh bien
voyez s'il ya de très nombreux enfants
qui sont contaminés
le nombre d'entre eux qui se
retrouveront à l'hôpital va continuer
d'augmenter dans les prochains jours les
prochaines semaines de façon inédite
l'argumentaire vis-à-vis des parents et
celui ci le vaccin est très efficace
chez les enfants le vaccin est très bien
toléré chez les enfants et donc nos
enfants n'encourt pas de risques
particuliers liés à la vaccination en
tout cas pas plus que les adultes comme
sommes et c'est le vieux continent tout
entier qui est confrontée aux mikron la
belgique sert un peu plus la vis et
ferme cinéma et théâtre les
professionnels du secteur sont en colère
et ont tenté de le faire savoir en ni
fait ce temps dans la journée
l'incompréhension était d'autant plus
grande que les experts consultés par le
gouvernement dans le cadre de la
pandémie elle n'avait pas recommandé la
fermeture des lieux de culture ces
restrictions doivent faire l'objet d'une
nouvelle évaluation début janvier
franklin ii où ce professeur à
l'université de liège et critique la
gestion européenne de la crise sanitaire
d'un côté il ya des aspects sur lesquels
il serait mieux d'avoir une réaction
collective plus forte notamment sur la
question des voyages et des blocages aux
frontières qui pose beaucoup de gens
beaucoup de problèmes aux gens et aussi
aux entreprises il faut pas oublier
qu'elles doivent continuer à fonctionner
dans le climat difficile actuel
maintenant en sens inverse l'europe fait
quand même certaines choses en commun
c'est certainement vrai pour les vaccins
nous en aurions beaucoup moins si on ne
les avait pas
gérer collectivement et c'est valable
aussi pour les les traitements les
médicaments qui commencent à arriver et
aussi pour la redistribution d'argent
pour essayer de maintenir un
fonctionnement des budgets donc il ya
certains résultats mais ce n'est pas
optimal dirais-je la chine berceau de
l'épidémie pays qui a réussi à réduire
le nombre de cas au minimum grâce à une
stratégie zéro co bit se retrouve
aujourd'hui confronté à une flambée de
l'épidémie dans certaines régions à
pékin est en état d' alerte alors
qu'elle se prépare à organiser les jeux
olympiques d'hiver elle reconfirme qian
13 millions de personnes sont concernées
quand un mot clair
la stratégie chinoise du zéro qu'ovide
mise à mal dans la province du shanxi
depuis jeudi les 13 millions d'habitants
de la ville de cyann sont confinés en
cause la découverte de plusieurs cas
positifs ces dernières semaines une
campagne massive de dépistage sur
l'ensemble des habitants a été organisée
sur place malgré ce le confinement
strict l'épidémie semble se propager
dans le reste du pays y compris à pékin
ce samedi des autorités ont recensé un
record de cas sur les quatre derniers
mois le 24 décembre 30 et une régions de
niveau provincial et le corps de
production et de construction du xixe
niang sur le continent chinois ont
signalé 140 nouveaux cas d'infection
confirmés 110 patients quitté l'hôpital
après avoir été guérie le nombre de cas
graves est resté inchangé hassiane
plusieurs désinfection des rues sont
organisées par les autorités des images
qui ne sont pas sans rappeler celle de
ou anne début 2020 seule une personne
par foyer est autorisé à sortir tous les
deux jours pour effectuer des achats de
première nécessité un service de
livraison de courses a été mise en place
pour éviter à la population de se
déplacer dans le même temps
des ambulances sont prêtes à intervenir
à tout moment deux ambulances sont en
attente dans la communauté pour fournir
un soutien médical si un habitant besoin
de services médicaux l'ambulance fournir
un service de navettes pour transporter
le patient ce regain épidémique en chine
intervient alors que les jeux olympiques
d'hiver se dérouleront à pékin dans un
peu plus d'un mois sans réelle solution
pour stopper drastiquement la
propagation du virus le comité
d'organisation créer un cluster lors des
deux semaines de l'événement mais se dit
prêt à une telle éventualité
ces jeux olympiques d'hiver se
dérouleront pendant la pandémie il y
aura certainement des contaminations il
est possible qu'une épidémie à très
petite échelle se produise car le risque
de transmission est très élevé lorsqu'un
grand nombre d'employés nationaux et
étrangers sur un ensemble nous avons
déjà mis en place des préparations et
des plans d'urgence très complet en cas
de contamination
après les jeux de tokyo l'été dernier le
co vite 19 pourrait donc bien perturber
une deuxième olympiade pour autant en
comparaison à d'autres pays la chine
reste pour le moment très peu touché par
la pandémie depuis l'apparition du virus
fin 2010 900 1871 cas symptomatiques et
moins de 5000 décès ont été recensés par
pékin
les combats s'intensifient au yémen
l'arabie saoudite qui dirige la
coalition militaire lance une opération
militaire de grande échelle dans le pays
une offensive qui répond à l'attaqué
mortelle mené par les outils sur le
territoire saoudien ryad accuse l'iran
et le hezbollah libanais d'avoir fourni
un soutien aux rebelles explication
médiers ce qui fit
une attaque mortelle menées sur le
territoire saoudien par les outils cela
n'était plus arrivé depuis près de trois
ans vendredi soir deux personnes ont été
tuées lors d'une offensive dans une
région près de la frontière avec le
yémen un acte rapidement revendiquée par
les rebelles chiites un projectile est
tombé sur un bâtiment commercial faisant
deux morts un saoudien et un résident
yéménite il a blessé sept civils dont
six saoudiens et un résident bengladais
une attaque qui a poussé le royaume a
lancé une nouvelle opération militaire à
grande échelle elle prévoit notamment un
appui à la coalition militaire qu'il
dirige et qui soutient le gouvernement
yéménite face aux rebelles une décision
qui pourrait aboutir à une
intensification des bombardements
aériens sur sanaa où trois civils sont
morts ce samedi la capitale sous blocus
saoudien depuis 2016 n'est plus en
mesure d'accueillir les avions
d'organisations humanitaires et des
nations unies en représailles à cette
intervention d'envergure les rebelles
promettent une réponse douloureuse à
ryad
nous promettons au régime saoudien d
opération douloureuse tant qu'il
poursuivra son agression et ses crimes
à sanaa la situation semble être
dramatique avec l'une des crises
humanitaires les plus importantes de la
planète
une situation qui pourrait encore
s'aggraver alors que 80% de la
population yéménite dépend des aides
internationales
d'après l'onu le conflit au yémen aura
provoqué la mort de trois cent soixante
dix sept mille personnes disent la fin
d'année 2021 et pour benoît un mur
ascione président de l'association
asters action sécurité tic républicaine
la communauté internationale a une
grande part de responsabilité dans ce
conflit notamment en raison des ventes
d'armes à l'arabie saoudite
il n'y a plus aucune protection pour les
populations civiles on a vu donc la
semaine dernière que l'aéroport de sanaa
a été bombardé et l'aéroport de sanaa
c'est bien entendu l'arrivée aussi de
l'aide humanitaire il y a encore une
fois
une organisation internationale qui sont
les nations unies et qui sont
complètement prise en otage par les cinq
pays membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité dont la france emmanuel macron
le président macron la semaine dernière
il ya deux semaines
s'est vanté d'avoir vendu 80 rafale aux
émirats arabes unis que desmond toutou
lequel faudrait rendre hommage à que
j'avais rencontré à new york avait
soutenu ce projet de traité on demande
donc aux états de d'arrêter de vendre
des armes à ces pays de participer à ces
crimes de guerre crimes contre
l'humanité et puis bien sûr il y aura le
temps de la justice individuelle
la cisjordanie théâtre de violentes
émeutes elles ont opposé manifestants
palestiniens aux forces de sécurité
israéliennes une centaine de personnes
ont été blessées les manifestants
protestaient contre des projets de
colonies illégales au regard du droit
international
dans la ville de burqa une situation
dénoncée par bruxelles qui appelle
israël à renoncer à ses projets de
colonisation farah mais qui
à cheikh jarrah
l'année se termine dans la violence
depuis quelques mois ce quartier de
jérusalem-est à majorité palestinienne
et le théâtre de nombreuses
manifestations
pour que près de 70 familles
palestiniennes sont menacés d'expulsion
par les autorités israéliennes et leurs
terrains saisis pour installer des
colons
images dont ordonné de quitter la maison
le 29 décembre cela fait soixante dix
ans que nous vivons dans cette maison
mes grands parents ma mère et moi
génération après génération new rave
notre enfance et nos vies sont dans
cette maison
les colons ont pris la décision de se
revendiquer propriétaire et pas
seulement de cette maison il revendique
toute la zone
ces colons ne craignent pas dû et ne
tienne compte de l'avis de personne le
gouvernement est avec eux la police est
avec eux et l'armée aussi qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire
face à face à cette situation les
émeutes s'intensifie et les heurts entre
autorités israéliennes et familles
palestiniennes se font de plus en plus
violents préoccupé par la situation
l'union européenne a envoyé une
délégation à jérusalem heureuse sur
place le chef de mission a exhorté
israël de mettre fin aux expulsions
pour nous l'union européenne ainsi que
pour nos partenaires ces colonies sont
illégales et jérusalem-est est un
territoire occupé selon le droit
international
les palestiniens ont pleinement le droit
de vivre ici
donc d'un point de vue à la fois
politiques juridiques mais aussi d'un
point de vue humanitaire je suis
consterné par ce que je vois ici
malgré la controverse internationale
depuis la prise de la cisjordanie par
israël lors de la guerre des six jours
en 1967
le nombre de colonies ne cesse
d'augmenter
désormais près de 500000 colons
israéliens occupent la zone où résident
deux millions cinq cent mille
palestiniens
et malgré les mises en garde sachez qu
israël vient d'approuver un plan pour
doubler le nombre de colons dans le
golan occupé une zone stratégique prise
à la série en 1967 et annexé il ya 40
ans en plan dont le coût s'élèvera à 280
millions d'euros on écoute le premier
ministre israélien
bogota
drame tout d'abord il faut dire que le
plateau du golan et israéliens cela va
de soi depuis 1981 le droit israélien
s'y appliquent et il est au dessus de
tout débat le fait que l'administration
trump les reconnu et le fait que
l'administration biden et précisé qu'il
n'y a pas de changement dans cette
politique est également important
chez nous et boum des mets aux autres la
gamba l'autre chez vous notre objectif
aujourd'hui est de doubler la
colonisation sur le plateau du golan
dakar inaugure ce lundi son nouveau ter
train express régional l'aboutissement
d'un projet de plus d'un milliard
d'euros qui doit mettre fin aux
embouteillages la capitale sénégalaise
présenté comme un succès pour le
président macky sall le ter est
néanmoins décriée par plusieurs
collectifs ils sont plusieurs milliers à
en effet avoir été expropriés pour les
besoins du projet les détails avec
maxime rosières
derrière ces murs il y avait la maison
de fatou dionne
dorénavant le terrain sur lequel elle a
vécu pendant plus de 40 ans servira de
site de maintenance pour le nouveau
train régional express de dakar
expropriés il y a quatre ans elle a dû
se reloger une solution de secours qui
lui coûte cher ça parle
depuis le 14 septembre 2010 est je suis
en location et je vis d'énormes
difficultés je ne peux pas rester dans
la rue je ne suis pas la seule il y en a
d'autres qui sont actuellement dans des
hôpitaux psychiatriques
d'autres sont décédés à cause du stress
et beaucoup de ménages ont été
disloquées à cause de ce train express
régional
d'après le collectif national des
impacts et du ter ils sont plus de 15
mille à avoir été expropriés pour le
projet de construction il réclame plus
de 76 millions d'euros à l'état si
c'était le poumon de l'emploi le poumon
de récupération des chauffeurs donc plus
de 5000 familles pouvaient le
quotidien dans ces lieux là qui a été
déguerpis de manière sauvage
simple par tous soient indemnisés sous
le par c'est le plan d'action et de
réinstallation de l'apix l' agence
publique qui a assuré la maîtrise
d'ouvragé du projet
selon agence 80 18,8 pour sont des
personnes affectées par le ter ont été
indemnisées tout a été transparent et
fait selon les normes internationales
des personnes ont été payés plusieurs
dizaines de millions de francs cfa et à
travaille toujours sur le recasement des
commerces et des ménages des mesures
jugées insuffisantes par le collectif
bien décidés à faire entendre sa voix
ils envisagent de bloquer le démarrage
du ter lundi pour son inauguration en
présence du président macky sall
la mobilisation ne faiblit pas au soudan
deux mois après le coup d'état militaire
du général bourhane ils étaient des
milliers dans la rue hier pour exiger un
retour des civils au pouvoir
des rassemblement émaillé de violences
notamment dans la capitale alors que les
autorités avaient bloqué les
télécommunications clément delcourt
des gaz lacrymogènes pour repousser les
manifestants qui tentent de se
rapprocher du palais présidentiel deux
mois jour pour jour après le coup d'état
des dizaines de milliers de
protestataires se sont rassemblés contre
le pouvoir militaire pour repousser la
foule l'armée active les canons à eau
jettent des grenades lacrymogènes et
chargé les manifestants faisant
plusieurs blessés des protestataires qui
réclament le départ des militaires au
pouvoir et la formation d'un
gouvernement choisi par le peuple
ce qu'il s'est passé le 25 octobre est
un coup d'état funeste il se poursuit
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire le
contraire
nous ne cesserons pas de manifester
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons un
gouvernement civil digne de ce nom et
cette fois le peuple participera à la
formation du gouvernement le peuple ne
sera pas seulement dans les rues pour
servir les intérêts des politiciens ou
de l'élite non cette fois les
manifestants sont dans la rue pour dire
que c'est eux qui décident
nous ne voulons pas seulement faire
tomber les soldats nous voulons avoir le
soudan que nous souhaitons vous un
soudan qui nous ressemble qui répondent
à nos demandes et donne des droits à
tous de manière équitable un mouvement
de contestation qui s'est répandue à
travers le pays à khartoum la capitale
mais aussi selon des témoins à madany
atbara ou encore port soudan dans l'est
du pays bien que les autorités ont de
nouveau coupé le réseau internet et les
communications téléphoniques dès le
début de la matinée une action dénoncée
par l'émissaire de l'onu pour le soudan
je demande instamment aux autorités
soudanaises et aux forces de sécurité de
protéger les manifestations prévues
aujourd'hui la liberté d'expression est
un droit de l'homme cela inclut le plein
accès à l'internet personne ne devrait
être arrêtée pour son intention de
manifester pacifiquement
depuis le putsch du 25 octobre dernier
et 48 manifestants ont été tués une
répression qui n'effraie pas les
soudanais puisqu'ils ont déjà annoncé
qu'ils manifesteraient de nouveau le 30
décembre prochain
ce bras de fer entre la société civile
et le pouvoir en place risque de durer
écoutez à ce sujet abdelkerim koundougou
me est chercheur associé au groupe
afrique de l'ip sauf
tous les actes posés
et le général khan et y montre très bien
que ils n'ont pas l'intention de rendre
le pouvoir aux civils en tout cas dans
le délai que la révolution a souhaité ou
les réunions la communauté
internationale a souhaité c'est à dire
en juillet 2023 si la tension augmente
aussi les répressions comme on a vu un
de la répression de cette dernière
manifestation et de la répression de là
il ya une semaine nous ça a fait des
morts et des blessés cette détermination
de l'armée et cette violence
disproportionnée que c'est de cette
jeune utilisent ce sens que le délai que
la communauté internationale souhaite ou
la substitution pour que ces pourparlers
de transférer au civil ne pourra pas
être respecté par les militaires
c'était il ya trente ans le président
soviétique mikhaïl gorbatchev annonçait
sa démission un départ qui va entraîner
la disparition de l'urss mais surtout la
naissance d'une nouvelle russie 15
républiques indépendantes et 14 autres
états retour sur cet événement qui a
bouleversé l'ordre mondial avec vera
goffman
26 décembre
1991 lempire du mal n'est plus la
nouvelle russie libérer des chaînes de
l'idéologie communiste se dirige
finalement vers un avenir radieux le
mode libre lui tend les bras fin de
l'oppression pour les peuples concernés
écrasé jusque là par le totalitarisme
mais au delà d'un tremblement de terre
géopolitique qu'est ce que c'est a
signifié pour les gens ordinaires ces
housses moi je vous fais ici
chez toi en raison de la situation qui
s'écrit avec la création de la
communauté des états indépendants
je mets fin à mes fonctions de président
de l'ue est restée dynastie la poste au
président jan gossaert ce furent des
jours noirs pour l'union et pour la
russie ce furent des jours noirs pour
moi aussi même si je n'ai pas perdu mon
sang-froid
j'ai signé un décret pour démissionner
de la présidence de l'urss je crois que
je n'avais pas le droit d'agir autrement
et les conséquences étaient graves les
gens ont perdu leurs économies
les revenus ont été divisés par 2 5
jusqu'à 80% de la population s'est
retrouvée sous le seuil de pauvreté les
chercheurs aller travailler sur les
marchés les ingénieurs dans les cafés
les médecins les professeurs étaient
parmi les plus pauvres touchant des
salaires de misère souvent versés en
retard pour des postes qui nécessite
pourtant plusieurs années d'études les
coupons pour acheter du sucre du lait du
pain sont entrés dans la vie des russes
pour longtemps dans le pays des signes
de guerre civile apparaissait et enfin
une guerre civile de grande ampleur a
éclaté évidemment j'ai vu tout cela
surtout quand je suis devenu directeur
du service fédéral de sécurité à cette
même époque notre système de protection
sociale avait été complètement détruit
certains secteurs économiques stoppé net
le système de santé était en ruines
l'armée s'est retrouvé dans un état
lamentable des millions et des millions
de gens se sont retrouvés à vivre sous
le seuil de pauvreté il ne faut pas
l'oublier
ça surtout mal tourné au sein des ex
républiques soviétiques des conflits
ethniques ont éclaté presque partout une
guerre entre la géorgie et l'abkhazie
entre la géorgie et l'institut du sud
conflit au nagorno karabagh bien suivi
le tadjikistan et beaucoup d'autres
encore je pense que la chute de l'urss
si vous voulez les accords de bivalves
hier
les indépendances tous et tout ça a été
perçu par la majorité des gens à
l'époque comme une espèce de tout
catastrophique et quand poutine a dit
que c'était une catastrophe je pense
qu'il a bien reflété le sentiment que
celui de la majorité des personnes y
compris pour des gens qui n'est pas
spécialement
qui était même favorable à la
pérestroïka ou qui étaient tout à fait
favorables à la démocratisation à la
libre expression qui était content de
sortir de la dune la période
autoritaire totalitaire soviétique
ça a été perçu comme une catastrophe
parce que c'était une catastrophe dans
la vie quotidienne pour les [ __ ]
repères étaient perdus ce sont des
années où j'ai vu vraiment des gens pris
de panique de nom mais comment on va
faire en fait sortir simplement derrière
les grandes décisions des hommes
politiques il ya toujours les gens
ordinaires qui subissent les
conséquences ceux qui ont décidé la
chute de l'urss applaudi par l'occident
ont aussi semé la misère et la mort pour
des milliers de russes et 30 ans près on
arrive toujours pas surmonté les
tragédies de cette époque c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain point sur l'actualité dans une
trentaine de minutes restez avec nous
sur rtl
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française allait aussi critiqué ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre et qu'une
catastrophe et